au cours de journées comme celle-ci ou
directement à le fs dix mille dons de
sang sont réalisés en moyenne chaque
année
il en faudrait près de 50% de plus alors
l'espoir vient de ces jeunes qui très
tôt répondre à l'appel ce matin hogan
sort tout juste de son examen de fin
d'année sur le campus
j'ai commencé à donner cette année lors
de ma majorité
et là c'est la deuxième fois que j'ai de
nouveau ça et ça ne change pas je
t'avais toujours un plaisir de donner
mon sang je me mets à la place des gens
il ya un problème de medicare j'aurais
bien aimé avoir dix ans aussi à recevoir
et pour pouvoir me des avis donc voilà
c'est juste la solidarité l envie
d'aider son prochain
en martinique la moitié des poches
collectées va aux personnes âgées 7%
sera transfusé aux accidentés
et puis il ya ceux qui seront transfusé
souvent dans leur vie certains malades
de cancer ou de la drépanocytose 15% des
transfusions
pour eux il est vital démultiplier les
dons de la population locale un
phénotype compatible à 30 % contre 5 %
seulement si le sang proviennent un type
caucasien pour tous ceux qui sont un
petit peu plus délicat je pense aux très
pâle aussi terme et pas que je pense aux
femmes enceintes
je pense aux jeunes filles qui
souhaitent avoir des enfants plus tard
je parle à tous ceux qui peuvent avoir
besoin de transfusions régulières
là on ne peut se retourner que sur nous
mêmes la compatibilité cool d'abord et
avant tout dans l'est dans les veines
des martiniquais martinique est une
question de phénotype c'est un petit peu
pointu une question de phénotype à ce
que tout le monde connaît son groupe
connaît son premier rhésus plus - mais
ça ne se définit pas uniquement comme ça
il ya beaucoup d'autres critères qui
permettent de définir la carte
d'identité sanguine de quelqu'un d'à
d'honneur d'un malade de quelqu'un dans
la population
parmi les 1500 à 2000 malades de la
drépanocytose les plus atteints auront
besoin d'être transfusés chaque mois en
fonction des cris pfff les enfants on
met en commun programme transfusionnelle
sont des enfants qui sont à risque de
faire une complication cérébrale donc
que l'on dépiste par des examens
appropriés comme le doppler transcrânien
et à qui on va proposer de les
transformer en neige pour éviter qu'ils
ne fassent un avc
c'est une complication grave de la
drépanocytose qui peut laisser des
séquelles importantes pour ces malades
au long cours les médecins sont très
conscients de la nes
cité transfuser un sens parfaitement
compatibles à défaut le patient risque
un rejet et une réaction très gras